[Music]
howdy
that's what Chief Dan George says in the
Outlaw Josey Wales
when he meets plenties for it he says
howdy howdy
hi mr. Freeman congratulations I'm over
here to your left right here hi ELISA
with blacks retv
hi Lisa first of all congratulations I
have an achievement award incredible
thank you can you tell us do you recall
when you first fell in love with acting
and what made you want to become an
actor
no I don't think I can tell you when I
first yes I can yes I can I got on stage
first time when I was 8 years old
I played a little boy blue in the
pageant power one of the things that was
aware of that I owned the stage at 8 so
about 12 there's no question hi Amanda
right over here with life and style hey
congratulations looking back over your
career what has been one of the most
challenging parts of your career or your
life and how did you overcome those
challenges 1980 at the end of 1980
December I finished a picture with
Cicely Tyson and that seemed to be it
found in rain through 1981 or 82 and I
thought my 15 minutes were up so
managing the state was a little bit of a
challenge because I needed to get a job
and I don't know why by the time I got
down to the moment when you make that
decision all right give it up and go get
a Jo be something good happen Paul
Newman came along so yeah
hi yes Dean huh hi mr. Freeman melody
Wayne's hall from Bonnie Alice hey
having won the Lifetime Achievement
Award what do you think about the awards
and the film industry being too white
can anybody interpret that for me having
the Lifetime Achievement Award what do
you think about the awards and the film
industry being 12 the film industry is
my life you know Joe being this showbiz
in my life and film industry let's hope
stays stays put and stays in the shape
what do I think about the award you have
to give that some thought because the
title is life achievement the inference
might be that get off the stage you're
done it might you don't know I mean so
it's the life achievement my hope is
that that's not the case that they were
saying congratulations so far fannia
Thomas with you our web mr. Freeman here
on the your left-hand side oh my
left-hand side yeah are you hi sir
Forbes magazine has named you the most
trustworthy celebrity five times in a
row every time that has been published
so I would like to know who do you think
is the most trustworthy celebrity aside
from yourself gosh there's an entire
list of people would he mean by
trustworthy
Tom Hanks right uh you know it it's the
exudes he exudes trust everything you've
seen Tom in you've liked you've
appreciated I know I have yeah he's just
but he's one of hundreds right okay
congratulations what a night you know a
lot of lucky things have happened to you
and a lot of people show you a
tremendous amount of respect and
affection can you add up at the best of
you
what part of this your spirit your drive
your own self has made this happen no no
I think the little horn Tooting I can do
for myself is merely having the courage
to keep going back in the hall they're
young people young actors struggling we
because I go along with it want to
assure them that it's best to keep going
don't don't give up I tell kids it's the
surest way to lose its equipment and in
this business it's really difficult
because there were so many talented
people out there scrambling to get
through that first Dewar that being able
to get there and do it is stroke of a
lot of things including luck thank you
thank you back here mr. Steve Futterman
from CBS radio hey graduations I want to
ask you if you can talk about this
server
cerebra cerebral question but I want to
know if you can talk about the
responsibility you as a performer have
to a role that you have to bring a
certain something to a row what do you
feel as your responsibility as an actor
when you get a role to bring to the
screen truth just find it and tell it
most screenplays you get they're telling
the story and inside the story in each
character is the truth of being that's
that's what you have to find and do good
enough say yes I mr. Fremont uh Mike
Snyder from indieWIRE congratulations
want to ask you real quick during your
speech just now on stage for a second
you stopped and said hello or
acknowledge someone in the audience can
you tell me who that was and and what
that was in reference to you know that
was Lily Tomlin yeah yeah I she's she's
a wonder in herself and I've always
loved her I see here I say hello
you